[Music]
welcome everyone to this I think the
final political debate of the festival I
think the only thing that emerged from
last night is that we are still very
much in uncharted territory so this
debate we will try to keep instead of
fighting the last war yet again we will
try to keep thinking about where we go
from here and what that future begins to
look like and I'm delighted to have with
me on the platform a splendid panel on
my far right mark Francois there was a
lot of that this morning Conservative
Party politician previously a Ministry
Minister of State at the Ministry of
Defence Armed Forces etc etc in 2018 he
was appointed the deputy chair and de
facto whip of the Euroskeptic european
research group led by its chair jacob
riis MOG Leon wood will be known around
here welsh politician former leader of
plied camry and member of the National
Assembly for Ronda since 2016 identifies
I'm told as a socialist a Republican and
a proponent of Welsh independence is
that a fair description that's about
right very good and Barry Gardner Barry
garden is a Labour Party politician he's
shadow Secretary of State for
international trade and for
international climate change I think we
could say voted remain absolutely but so
he's a recovering remain voter and and
Anatole collects key known to many of
you I'm sure the Economist and writer
gosh a long and distinguished career
award-winning commentator columnist for
The Times so I'm going to invite all of
the panelists beginning with mark to lay
out their pitch really on on the on the
kind of opening question of where Oh
we're Britain's heading what is
Britain's future mark on this momentous
morning madam Jim
colleagues ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for inviting me to
participate in this very timely debate
you said you wanted to look forward so I
think it's because of last night for
reasons we can get into I think it's now
even more likely that we will leave the
European Union on the 31st of October
2019 that is now the legal default
position but I don't think that we want
to go to No Deal as a desired end state
the desired end state that we want is a
comprehensive free trade agreement with
our European partners which would allow
us to trade with them with low or no
tariffs to our mutual economic advantage
into the foreseeable future there is
already such an agreement between the EU
and Canada that was signed in 2016 so
there is already a strong precedent
which the EU have accepted by virtue of
the fact they've signed it so what we
would do is take that existing agreement
as a template modify it probably add a
protocol on data one on security because
of our important security commitments in
Europe some other changes that's known
conceptually as super Canada and we
would go forward with that so while I'm
personally I've never accepted project
fear I would be prepared to go through a
brief period of training on WTO terms
often referred to as no deal to get to
super Canada to be clear no deal is not
the desired outcome it's a free trade
agreement and very quickly my boss Jacob
Riis MOG has recently written a book
Steve Baker's writing a book so not so
as not to be left out I'm going to write
a book slightly about brexit but more
about the mad life of a member of
parliament in the 21st century and I'm
going to call it you couldn't make it up
I haven't got a publisher yet so I
thought I'd announce it at the Hay
Festival
so if any of you are connected in the
literary words please see me afterwards
for a 5% cut thank you very much madam
chair
well I'm very relieved to hear you
couldn't make it up because I've had a
suspicion in the last few months that a
lot of people be making a lot of things
up so hey Leon
where's Britain headed well I think we
could go in two different directions
really the European election results
last night showed me that while they may
if you add up all the pro remain parties
be a slight majority now four remain
it's still very close I don't think it's
as decisively changed as much as I I
would like it to have and I think that
it shows that if if brexit does happen
in October and a new harder right leader
of the Conservatives then we could end
up going out without a deal which for
Wales certainly and and specific
specific industries like our farm and
industry would be absolutely awful we
could be looking at a situation where
everything is is done to try and make a
trade deal with the United States
amenable and I could include us having
to privatize or make big changes to our
NHS for example or we could take a
completely different approach to all of
this and refuse completely to take the
the path of the the far right and and
the path that they want to take us down
with increased hate crime misogyny
racism and all those other things that
we've seen for the last few years we
could do something completely
differently and this is why I support
independence for Wales it's not
something that can happen tomorrow but I
think that if we worked in our
communities and built from the
grassroots up a different kind of
politics a politics which was aiming for
self-sufficiency using the amazing
natural resources that we've got in our
communities that are untapped at the
moment our human resources our energy
resources our food resources we could
bear
independence from the bottom up and
build resilience into our communities in
case things go pear-shaped like I fear
that they could thank you very much
Anatole I think actually so far the
reporting the results last night have
been rather misleading as a big triumph
for the brexit party in particular and
the forces of no deal or hard brexit in
general that was how the story looked
like it was going to turn out and as a
former as a recovering journalist I can
tell you there's a lot of inertia in the
way that the journalists think about the
world they tend to see what they expect
to see the fact is that last night was a
pretty stunning surprise and the really
surprising and unexpected story last
night was actually was it was a big
defeat for the forces of no deal and
hard brexit I'm not saying it's not
going to happen but the result was
brexit party plus UK plus Tories 44% of
the total vote the clearly remained
parties Lib Dems greens like Kumari etc
plus labour 54% of the vote so 44 to 54%
now we're going to hear from Barry in a
minute whether labour really is a
romaine party or not under the circuit
under the circumstance of that in which
we now find ourselves of a potential no
deal or very basic Canada plus but I
think if it turns out that Labour is now
really no main party then in voting
terms we have a 54:44 difference which
is quite a significant one in terms of
seats is even more surprising because in
the current European Parliament there
were 43 seats either for you Kip or for
the Tories against only 27 pro-eu seats
in the new European Parliament the
majority has flipped the other way there
are going to be 37 Pro eum
peas and that clearly includes all the
Labour MPs who elected against only 33
UK plus stories so actually it was quite
a remarkable outcome now the result of
that I think looking forward is that
whoever is the next Tory leader will
face a situation in which he was at all
my certainty will be he will have
promised to the Conservative Party that
he is willing to take Britain out on a
No Deal basis by October 31st and the
top and only priority is to get out on
October 31st regardless of the
circumstances but in practice he will
not be able to do that because although
the current mark is absolutely right
that the current default legislation is
that Britain leaves on October 31st Deal
or No Deal the same was true on March
29th this year and the fact is there was
no majority in parliament to allow that
and now I think there's going to be an
even clearer majority in parliament to
prevent no deal
partly because four of mark's colleagues
have already left the party so the
conservative majority even with the DUP
is now either 5 or 8 depending on how
you calculate it so it's much smaller it
would only take between 3 & 5
conservatives to flip to actually defeat
the government and partly also I think
because it'll be so overwhelmingly
against the personal interests of the
new Conservative leader to risk a
general election that he would never be
prepared to put himself into the
situation where label would be able and
willing to call a confidence vote some
other dates tops communities subscribe
today
to the Institute's of Austin ideas III
TV